في ذروة الصيف في أبو
ظبي ، يكون الجو حارًا ، ولا مفر
منه حتى الآن
[موسيقى]
انظر إلى هذا ، هذا أمر رائع للغاية ،
لقد حصلت على كارتون جنكشن
على الساقين هناك أنا ذاهب بهذه
الطريقة  أنا ذاهب إلى مدينة جوثام ، اتبعني
مسرح مولوخ ، أرقى مسرح بمدينة جوثام ،
وأرى waynetech هنا ، على الرغم من
[موسيقى]
[ضحك
] باتمان الذي تم العثور عليه تمامًا ، كيف يمكنك
أن تقابلك جيدًا ، ومرحبًا بك أيضًا في
البستانيين ، هل ترغب في مساعدتي
حافظ على جوثام بأمان ، أود مساعدتك في
الحفاظ على جوثام آمنة
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اللغز في الوحي ، هل
تجرؤ علي
[موسيقى]
سنصدقها مرحبًا ، لقد أحببت ذلك ، لقد رأيت بعض الألغاز
ذات الأوزان تفعلها اثنان من
إنه أمر رائع للغاية وهي
الأصالة التي تشعر أنك
منغمس فيها تمامًا في التجربة أعتقد أنها
كانت مخيفة على أي حال ، نعم
لن يعترف بذلك ، نعم ، دعني
أجرب ارتفاعات أخرى